-Guys, it is time for "Good
Name, Bad Name, Great Name."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Good names, bad names,
great names, yes ♪
-First up, we have
"Gone in 60 Seconds."
Well, that's a good name
for a Nicolas Cage movie...
a bad name for your
New Year's resolution...
[ Light laughter ]
...a great name for CVS's supply
of at-home COVID tests.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You got to get there quick.
Next up, there's Fall Out Boy.
That's a good name
for a pop punk band...
a bad name for a BabyBjorn.
[ Light laughter ]
And a great name
for a skydiving school.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After that,
we've got "Yellowstone."
Well, that's a good name
for a TV Western.
It's a bad name
for a jewelry store.
[ Light laughter ]
And a great name for
the gravel at a dog park.
Oh, interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next up, there's
"Who Want Smoke??"
Well, that's a good name
for a song by Nardo Wick.
A bad name
for an air filtration system.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name for
a vape store owned by a caveman.
[ Applause ]
"Who Want Smoke??"
[ Applause continues ]
Next up, there's
"Nightmare Alley."
Well, that's a good name
for a movie.
It's a bad name for
an Airbnb listing.
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name for
a proctologist.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
That's a great name?
-Mm-hmm.
Next up, there's
"The Music Man."
That's a good name
for a musical.
A bad name for a mime.
A great name for when your mom
is trying to remember
Post Malone's name.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"The, uh...
The Music Man."
After that, we've got
"That's My Jam."
That's a good name
for my new show on NBC.
That's a bad name for
a Spotify playlist
that's just four hours
of "whale sounds."
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name for a
fistfight at a farmer's market.
"Hey! That's my --"
[ Applause ]
-"It's boysenberry!"
-And finally, we have
"How I Met Your Father."
Well, that's a good name
for a brand-new TV show.
It's a bad name
for a sperm bank.
[ Light laughter ]
It's a great name for a "Maury."
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's all we have for "Good
Name, Bad Name, Great Name."